[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'ex pdg d'orpea a vendu ses actions
l'at-il fait sachant qu'une enquête
risquer de ternir l'image du groupe et
que le cours en bourse d'orpea alice
s'effondrer c'est ce qu'affirme ce matin
le canard enchaîné peu plus de dégoût
encore s'il en fallait et puis je trouve
que ça montre un certain cynisme ce pdg
était là depuis 28 ans donc on vous
voyait bien qu'on est au coeur d'un
système il y aurait un système
orpea qui consisterait à
optimiser le profit pour rogner sur nos
prestations pour rationnés nos
prestations il empoche alors
580000 157 euros au moment de cette
vente l'action orpea vos 107 rouge
depuis la sortie du livre elle a
dégringolé à 39 euros ce système
morgaine n'existe en aucun cas dans nos
ehpad cher paiera j'ai le sentiment que
vous fichez nous quand vous parler
d'humanisme quand vous parler d'acte de
bienveillance par la bouche quand vous
parlez de vos valeurs qui sont avant
tout boursière et en plus parfois avec
des lois larmoyante quand vous nous
dites que c'est pas un système mais bien
sûr que c'est un système si on augmente
le rsa 30% les gens restent sous le
seuil de pauvreté quand même
oui mais on y ajoute on y ajoute voilà
on peut y ajouter
l'apl d'une part
ok
je considère qu' il y a il y à la
nécessité de revoir la totalité des
minima sociaux le syndicat de policiers
a invité les candidats à la
présidentielle à se mettre je cite face
à la réalité des flics exactement chaque
candidat avec 45 minutes la peur doit
changer de camp la peur changera de camp
aurait armé les policiers la nation doit
protéger ceux qui la protègent et
protégé pour qu'ils puissent de nouveau
nous protège et présidente de la
république je serai à vos côtés ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que jamais je ne
dirai qu'il ya des violences policières
dans la société il n'y a pas de violence
policière les policiers ont selon la
grande phrase de max weber le monopole
de la violence légitime donc qu'il y à
des violences faites aux policiers wii
et qui se multiplient nous devons à
l'égard des fonctionnaires obligés de
réagir pour protéger leur vie ou celle
de leurs collègues établir une
présomption de légitime défense
et même une présomption de légitime
défense renforcée oui il faut réformer
la police de la cave au grenier une
somme radicalement opposé à toutes les
propositions qui ont été faites dans le
sens est aux policiers c'était
est-ce que vous avez l'impression d'être
à votre place en précédant de candidats
d'extrême droite moi je suis là parce
que la démocratie exige qu'on discute et
qu'on discute évidemment avec un
syndicat de police que je respecte
profondément l'habitation a été décliné
par tous les candidats sauf jean luc
mélenchon pour les insoumis qui n'a pas
été conviée après ses déclarations lui
demande pour un syndicat c'est un
groupement d'extrême droite dans la
police qu'à un comportement indigne
d'une police républicaine
voilà toute alliance alliance il insulte
et menace gymnase des juges par les
propos qu'il tient monsieur mélenchon ne
répondent que haine et d information
comment inviter quelqu'un qui nous
traitent d'ultraviolence de factieux
tous les quatre matins vous allez rares
sous les yeux un tiers un tigre projeter
sur l'eiger enfui en suisse
c'est la dernière oeuvre de l'artiste
guéri hoffstetter la projection est
impressionnante elle mesurait plus de
cinq kilomètres de long et 2 km2